- Hello.
I'd like you to think
about a time recently
where you needed to research
or analyze something complex.
If you're in IT or engineering,
perhaps you had to research
what other companies
in your space are doing
with AI assisted coding agents,
to figure out what makes
sense for your organization.
Or maybe you're in marketing.
And so for your research
might have been looking at
what your competitors are doing
to develop a marketing plan
or an advertising strategy.
Or maybe you are, like me,
you're in product management
and you were digging into
customer feedback to figure out
what new features you should build
or what the roadmap should look like.
Or maybe you're a business analyst
or you're in business intelligence
and you needed to dig
into your internal metrics
and dashboards to figure
out the root cause
of an issue that you're experiencing.
The fact is all across your organization,
there are probably users
today who are doing research
as part of their day-to-day jobs,
even though they may not have research
in their official job title.
The problem is that business
research is challenging,
as I'm sure most of the folks here
would attest to.
So for instance,
there's not enough time.
Doing high quality,
deep research takes time
that we oftentimes don't have.
Sometimes the information
that we're trying to access
is stored in disparate systems
and we don't have access to it.
Or maybe you don't even know
what information your
company subscribes to
that you should have access to.
Or let's say you're
doing internet research.
I'm sure we've all had the
experience of finding a website
that has information that's
outdated or unreliable.
Or, you know, perhaps
you're trying to do research
using one of the new AI tools,
but it's not approved to
handle your company data,
or the results that you're getting
are just not reliable
enough to use in your work.
To address these problems,
we built Quick Research.
Quick Research provides the most accurate
and reliable AI research.
It works across enterprise data, the web,
and premium third party data sources
to deliver verifiable expert
level insights in minutes.
My name is Jon Einkauf.
I'm a principal product manager at AWS,
I work on Quick Research specifically.
During the next couple of minutes,
I'm gonna give you a brief
overview of Quick Suite
and then I'm gonna go a little bit deeper
on Quick Research specifically.
Next we're gonna have Nicki Susman,
enterprise AI tech lead at
Principal Financial Group,
talk to us about how
Principal Financial Group
is using Quick Research.
And then finally, my
colleague, Natalie Hirsch,
gen AI specialist at AWS,
is gonna be joining us
to talk about how you
can automate research
and is gonna walk us through
a case study from AstraZeneca
so we can see it in
action in the healthcare
and life sciences industry.
So let's get started.
Quick Suite, Amazon Quick Suite,
is an agentic AI application
for business users.
It pulls together all of your data
and applications to make it easier for you
to access the data that you need
and to take action in the tools
that you use as part of your work.
There's a lot going on with Quick Suite.
I'll just give you a couple of highlights.
Spaces is a feature that
helps you organize files,
dashboards, and data sources
so that you can collaborate
with teammates and give
access to company knowledge
to agents that you create.
Chat agents helps you
create custom AI assistants
that have access to your company data
and third party data.
Research is what we're gonna
go deeper on in this session.
This is for when you need to
do complex business research
or analysis that would
ordinarily take hours,
days, or even weeks.
Quick Sight is a service that
lets you visualize your data,
create and share dashboards.
Many of the folks in this room may be
using Quick Sight already.
Quick Flows is a feature
that helps you automate common tasks
in your day-to-day work,
getting ready for meetings,
sending emails, things like that.
Automate is for automating more
complex business processes.
So Quick Research is used in
a large variety of use cases.
So I'm just gonna highlight a few here.
So if you are in sales,
you can use something like Quick Research
to analyze a company
to prepare a sales plan
or to prepare for a meeting.
Somebody in marketing
might use Quick Research
to analyze customer data, market trends,
to develop marketing plans,
marketing strategies.
Somebody in policy or regulatory
might use a tool like this
to evaluate how laws and regulations
that are ever evolving
may impact your business.
Somebody in product might
use Quick Research to come up
with new product ideas
or to refine a roadmap.
A business analyst
or a business intelligence
engineer might use it
to dig into metrics to
prepare for a weekly
or a monthly business review.
Somebody in M&A or corp development
might use Quick Research
to do due diligence on a company
that you're considering
acquiring or partnering with.
One of the things that makes
Quick Research so powerful
is that it supports a wide
range of data sources.
It starts with your own company data.
So if you have documents,
files in OneDrive, SharePoint,
other knowledge bases like
this, you can pull it in
and do research on those sources.
If you have files in S3,
you can pull those in.
If you have dashboards in Quick Sight
or you have files in spaces,
you can pull those into the research.
You can also upload your
own files from your laptop,
if that's part of the research plan.
Of course, it can also
search across the web.
One of the things that's really powerful
about Quick Research
is that you can control
what websites the agent is using.
So if you have a list of websites
that you wanna prioritize
or a list of sites that you want to avoid,
you can provide that to the agent.
It will steer where the agent
is getting its information.
We also support hundreds
of premium media outlets
from websites like The New York
Times, the Associated Press,
Forbes, Washington Post,
and hundreds of others.
And as of last week, we announced support
for third party data
sources, S&P Global, IDC,
FactSet, PubMed.
This is just the start,
we're gonna be adding
more and more premium third
party data sources over time
and we're very excited about that
because it continues
to increase the quality
and the depth of the research
that you can produce.
So let's see it in
action, I'm gonna show you
with a simple example how you use the tool
and I'll point out a few things as we go.
So what we're looking at here is the
homepage for Quick Suite.
If you look on the left,
you'll see a navigation pane.
This is where you access
all of those features
that I was talking about
earlier, flows, chat agents,
faces, research.
We're going to click on
the research tab here
to see the research, the
Quick Research homepage.
What you're seeing here is a
list of the research reports
that have been run in
this account recently.
I'm gonna click on the
button at the top right
that says new research.
So on this page is where
you configure your research,
and this is, we've designed this
to be extremely simple to use.
So what you're gonna start with
is adding your research
objective at the top left.
So this is your prompt,
or your research goal.
For this example, what we're gonna do is,
I'll read it aloud in case
you can't read off the screen.
The font is a little bit small.
It says "Create a gen AI
strategy for a major US airline.
Include an analysis of
what competitors are doing,
identify 10 high priority use cases,
describe the technical
and organizational factors
that are required for success,
and develop a three year
implementation plan."
So this is fairly complex.
There's a lot going on here.
I would expect something like this
to ordinarily take a few
days, maybe a few weeks.
Using this tool,
you actually get back a 20
page report in 20 minutes.
Once you've added your
research goal, you know,
look at the bottom left,
this is where you configure
what sources you want
to use in your research.
So for this example, I'm
just gonna use web search
and I'm gonna add a third
party data provider, IDC,
because I know that IDC
provides a wealth of insights
for the technology market
and it probably has some
interesting insights
on gen AI strategies.
Now if you were actually
working at an airline
doing this research,
you would probably add some company files.
You might add some
documents from SharePoint.
I'm not gonna do that for this example,
but if you wanted to, the
way you would do that is
through the little tab that
says Quick Suite assets.
So once I'm happy with
the research prompt,
I'm gonna click the button, create plan.
This is where I've selected IDC.
So once I click create plan,
about 20, 30 seconds later,
I'm gonna view this research plan.
What this is, is it's a list of the topics
that the agent is gonna
go and investigate.
And if I'm happy with this, I can go ahead
and execute the research,
but I can also refine it.
And so let's say I wanna
make a change to the plan.
The way I do that is in the
little text box on the right,
I can add a comment.
You'll also notice there,
there are some recommendations
from the agent that I can choose
to address or not address.
So in this case, the agent
is saying, "You know,
you might wanna specify which airline,"
which I didn't include in my prompt.
The agent is also recommending, "You know,
maybe you should provide parameters
around what's your budget for this."
So I find oftentimes these recommendations
are pretty helpful.
For now, I'm gonna skip through this
and we're just gonna start the research,
but in the real world,
you would probably wanna
look at these recommendations
and refine the plan.
So I'm gonna click the
button, start researching.
At this point, the research kicks off,
it will typically take about
20 minutes to complete,
it may be a little less, it
may be a little bit more.
It depends on how many
data sources you're using,
how complicated your research goal is.
But 20 minutes is about average.
While the research is happening,
you can watch it in action.
So you can see what the agent is doing,
what websites is it looking at,
what insights is it developing.
You can also just close
the tab and come back.
You'll get a notification
when the research is done.
When the research is complete,
you'll see a page like this.
This is what the final
research report looks like.
And as I mentioned earlier,
it's quite thorough.
This, it may be 20 pages, 30 pages long.
If we scroll through it,
one of the sections in the
report that I asked for
is a roadmap.
So this is a Gantt chart
view of the roadmap
where it's showing all of the initiatives
described earlier in the report
and then laying it out time-wise.
Now, if I read the line
right before the chart,
right after the chart, it says
the implementation timeline follows
a structured three phase
approach based on BCG's
deploy, reshape, invent framework.
Now, I have not heard of
this framework before.
Let's say as a user, I wanna dig in
and understand that better.
What I'm gonna do is you'll
notice there's a little icon
that says 11.
I'm gonna click on that
and it's gonna tell me
where that came from.
And if I want, I can click on this
and it will deep link,
it'll open a new tab
and deep link me into that article.
I can read all about it.
Throughout the whole
report you'll see lots
of source citations, which
is really helpful for you
to understand more detail
about what's in the report.
All right, so let's say I keep scrolling,
and in the section of the report
that talks about the key use cases,
one of the use cases here is using gen AI
to develop a customer
service conversational AI
and customer service automation.
So let's say as a user, I'm
really interested in that
and I want more detail.
All I need to do is highlight the text
or add a global comment in the report
and I can ask for more detail.
So in this case, I've
highlighted the words
customer service automation
and I've added the comment,
"Create a dedicated
section on this topic."
The agent will take that
feedback and it will go
and work on that and it'll come back
and the report will be updated
with a brand new section, maybe a page
or two pages just on that topic.
And so you can go through this
and you can keep iterating with the agent
until you get the research to be exactly
what you need for your purposes.
Now if I keep going,
you may have noticed if you're,
it's maybe a little hard
to see on the screen, but
there's a little icon here
with some bars and a plus sign.
You'll see that throughout
the report in places
where the statement is complex.
So maybe it's using multiple sources
or there's a complex
calculation that's happening.
And so when you click on
this icon, it will bring up
a right pane where you can dig
into that statement in depth.
You can see all the sources
that are being used,
the content within those sources.
If there are logical
inferences being made,
it explains the logic.
So we refer to this feature as tracing
and it's really helpful when
you've got a complex statement
that you really need to unpack.
Now I said earlier, this
report is quite long.
You may not wanna read
20 pages or 30 pages.
Let's say what you really
want is an executive summary,
two pages long.
What you're gonna do then is
click on the little button
at the top right that says summarize.
It will bring up this page.
You can either provide
custom instructions for
how you want the summary to be created
or you can just select one of the presets.
In this example, I'm just
gonna click on the button
that says executive summary.
And about 30 seconds
later I'll have a crisp
one and a half, two page summary
that I can then download and share.
So hopefully this gives you
a sense of how easy it is
to use Quick Research
and also a sense of how
it can provide value
for users across your organization.
Next we're gonna hear from Nicki
from Principal Financial Group.
She's gonna talk to us about
how Principal Financial Group
has been using Quick Research
and some of the lessons that
they've learned along the way.
- Awesome, thank you Jon.
So I'm gonna start off with a
brief overview of who we are.
Principal is a global
financial services company
with specialized solutions
helping people, businesses,
and institutions reach their
long-term financial goals
and access greater financial security.
We have an integrated
business model across
retirement, benefits and protection,
and asset management, working
together to deliver holistic
and customizable solutions
to more than 71 million customers
in more than 80 markets around the world.
We have nearly 20,000 global employees
with about 4,000 in IT.
And they all work together
across all business functions
with one shared focus,
to continuously improve the experience
for every customer we serve.
I'm here today to tell you
about our real world story,
our challenge, our journey, our wins,
what worked and what didn't,
and what genuinely
surprised us along the way.
So let's get started.
What if I told you that our
biggest win from Quick Research
wasn't actually solving the problem
that we set out to solve?
It was discovering new
research opportunities
that we never knew we had time for.
We started with a strong use case.
Our private market products team
and our real estate
asset management division
needed to establish two new funds.
And that traditional research process
took three to four weeks per fund.
Establishing a fund requires
comprehensive research
across competitive analysis,
market opportunities,
regulatory requirements,
investment strategy,
operational infrastructure and more.
And all of those are key components
to determine the fund's
viability and structure.
Our problem was not a lack of expertise,
it was where that expertise was going.
Our analysts were spending their time
on manual internet searches, requests,
and curating market reports
instead of actually analyzing the data
and developing those investment insights.
We saw an opportunity to
transform this process
with Quick Research, and we started
by using just publicly available data
to validate our approach
and prove out the platform.
What immediately surprised the team
was that Quick Research didn't
just make research faster
and enhance what they did.
It actually allowed them
to produce more in-depth
research at a higher quality
than they previously would've been able
to justify the time for.
Even with just publicly
available data, the team was able
to reduce their timeline
from three to four weeks
down to one week.
And when they were able to stop asking,
"Do we have time to research that?"
they were able to start asking,
"What else should we be researching?"
How many of you have great
ideas that never get researched
because they would just take too long?
Yes, that is exactly what changed for us
because word about Quick
Research spread so fast,
we went from that one use case
to teams across the entire enterprise
asking for access basically overnight.
We had software engineers
using it for technical research
and vendor evaluations.
We had enterprise architects leveraging it
for strategy assessments.
We had our investment, our marketing,
different strategy teams
all finding new applications
from due diligence to regulatory research.
But we also had an unexpected outcome.
You heard Jon talk about
Quick Suite as this ecosystem
with all of these tools,
and our users started getting
excited not just about
Quick Research as a standalone tool,
but the entire Quick Suite ecosystem.
Could they upload research
to a shared space?
Could teams from other departments
build on the same research foundation?
Our team started imagining
these custom agents
and automated workflows
and most importantly,
breaking down the silos
between teams and departments.
Because of this, Quick
Research became our proof point
for what was possible
and we were excited to see it start
going across the enterprise
for all of these different
diverse use cases.
But there were a couple key capabilities
that really made it effective
for enterprise teams
and specifically within Principal.
First and foremost,
we loved the persistent
research capability
because you can go back to
old research, you can edit,
you can refine, you can
then share that out,
summarize like Jon shared.
But when we were going through this,
we learned to always double check
where the data was pulling from,
because as teams started
integrating those internal sources,
we learned that our proprietary data made
a night and day difference
in terms of reliability, accuracy,
as we started building
on these different research foundations.
We also found that Quick
Research's transparency,
which again, Jon shared,
really helped our users learn
to trust the platform.
Because we were able to see exactly
where a claim was being pulled from,
users were able to dive deeper
into these complex insights
and ensure that the reasoning
behind those insights was accurate
and valid for their use cases.
But what we found really
set Quick Research apart
from traditional tools was again
that ecosystem integration,
but with the security controls
that made us comfortable leveraging
our company confidential data within it
for that advanced research.
But one of our users
really put it perfectly,
Quick Research excels when you're trying
to uncover solutions that
your teams might be blind to.
And this is especially critical
for filling knowledge gaps
like architecture questions
or organizational structure challenges.
But none of this matters
if you don't know how
to ask the right question.
We're all familiar with
prompt engineering,
it's been all the rage
for like two years now.
We know about prompt engineering.
But Quick Research takes
it to a different level.
Let me show you what I mean.
And I promise, you don't
have to read this slide,
I'm gonna talk through
everything that's on here,
but this is just an example
of one of our prompts
to show you what we found worked
best within Quick Research.
And I actually had to
trim this down quite a bit
to make it fit on this slide.
But first and foremost,
and I think it's quite obvious,
this works because it's
not a simple sentence
or a single request, it is
structured and detailed.
We start specific, instead of
saying "Tell me about GDPR,"
we specifically call out
US-based asset managers
with global operations,
and this immediately eliminates thousands
of irrelevant research results.
We break it into clear
sections, core requirements,
industry impact, compliance integration,
implementation framework.
And this helps Quick Research
structure its approach
as it conducts the research.
Next, we tell it exactly where to look,
European data board protection guidelines,
authority guidance, recent
enforcement actions.
And finally this is what
we ask for at the end.
A practical compliance checklist,
risk assessment matrix,
implementation timeline.
Because we want tools that
our teams can immediately use
and not just another report
that they have to sit there
and read.
But what we found is
that Quick Chat excels
when you are very precise
about what you want,
where it's gonna be used,
and how you're going to use it.
That specificity wins when
it comes to Quick Research.
But this level of prompt
mastery did not come
to our users naturally, believe it or not.
One of the things that we found was
that using Quick Chat
really helped us refine
and iterate on our prompts.
'Cause the platform is self-aware,
it's able to provide suggestions
and recommendations on
how to improve the prompt
to become more precise.
But this is just one thing.
We teach our users prompt engineering,
we teach them how to
write the correct prompt,
but when it comes to implementation,
we need to talk about
organizational strategy as well.
So some of the key lessons that
were the difference between
that single use case and
enterprise wide demand are here.
First and foremost, the
technical implementation
is straightforward.
And I say that with a
background in engineering,
I know how complex things can get,
but you literally just
log into Quick Suite
and Quick Research is there.
We already had security groups
configured in our Azure tenant
that we were able to immediately
leverage within Quick Suite
because of its native
identity center integration.
So all of the user
onboarding natively followed
our enterprise guidance for
identity and access management
without having to jump through hoops,
which was amazing.
But secondly, we found
that governance matters
more than you think.
So upfront establish
clear guidelines about
what data can be included in Quick Suite
and Quick Research, how
that data gets stored,
how it gets shared,
who has access to what.
It's your standard data governance
and AI governance questions,
but on a bit of a broader scale
because Quick Suite does have
so many different functions
and foundations within it.
Next, we found comprehensive user training
was absolutely critical.
Both prompt engineering,
how to use the tool,
what to do with the outcomes,
all the way down to what is an agent.
So make sure that you're
training your users
on all the possibilities
of Quick Research,
as well as the entire ecosystem.
But don't just stop at doing
it with your early adopters.
Plan to scale that training
as your adoption grows.
Next, and this one might
be the most important,
get executive sponsorship early.
Make sure your leadership
knows what's going on
and make sure that they understand
that this tool isn't just
about faster research,
it's about competitive advantage
through knowledge transformation.
Really think about what
happens when success scales.
Teams are gonna want to create
those shared research repositories
and integrate your confidential data.
And all of these things are going
to require leadership buy-in.
And if you don't have that from the start,
you will hit organizational roadblocks
that no amount of technical
success can overcome.
And the last one, this is a bit more fun,
is plan for success.
Because when this works,
it's going to work fast.
You will have organic adoption
across your enterprise.
So you need to make sure
that your infrastructure
and your support model can
scale with that demand.
So these lessons shaped
how we're scaling Quick
Research across Principal,
because we found that when
you get that foundation right,
the next exciting challenge
is the growth that comes next.
So to wrap this up, where are we today?
Well, we're live in production.
We are actively onboarding
what we call high value use cases,
but not necessarily high dollar value.
It's the scenarios
that really showcase Quick Research's
differentiating capabilities
and true potential in our environment.
We are building momentum
and we're actively
establishing our roadmap
based on these real world outcomes.
And the diversity of teams wanting access
continues to surprise us.
But let me leave you with this.
Quick Research isn't just
about getting faster answers,
it's about asking bigger
and better questions.
Because when you give your
teams the ability to dive deeper
and explore blind spots,
you're not just increasing productivity,
you're creating advantage
through knowledge transformation,
faster decision making, and
that faster market response.
We didn't just speed up our research.
That three to four weeks
down to one week was amazing,
but don't get me wrong,
and we're continuing to work
through that and improve it.
But we fundamentally changed
our relationship with curiosity
because teams started
tackling strategic questions
that they had never even proposed before
because that barrier to
exploration had disappeared.
My advice to you is don't
just think about your current
strategic research bottlenecks.
Think about the strategic questions
that your teams aren't even asking
because they seem too big to tackle,
because that is where Quick Research
is going to create transformation.
And that shift from
efficiency to curiosity
is exactly where innovation
becomes inevitable.
And when teams start asking
those bigger questions,
well that's exactly why Natalie's here
to walk you through how Quick Flows
automates what comes next.
Natalie?
- Thank you Nicki.
So hi everyone, I'm Natalie Hirsch,
I'm on the Amazon Quick
Suite go to market team,
and my job is to work with
customers like yourselves
as well as with our
field and partner teams
to help them understand
how Quick Suite can
truly transform the way
your employees are working.
So I know this latte on your
screen has you thinking about
your next coffee break,
but I want you to stay with me
for just a couple more minutes.
So I don't know about you,
but I personally like end
up reaching out for coffee
when I know I have to do
repetitive work, right?
And a lot of times that work
can be very, very important,
but right in my head I'm thinking,
"Oh, I know how to do this,
it's just gonna take me
a little bit longer,"
always longer than I plan on, right?
So I grab my coffee,
and with research tasks in particular,
I actually love the
research side of things,
but by the time I have
to start summarizing
and writing that, especially in a format
that my leadership is expecting,
I've probably downed three coffees.
So just take a second,
think about like if you have
similar situations, right?
At some point in your process, right,
where you find yourself
reaching out for coffee,
and that's frustrating,
and let's talk about maybe a scenario
where we can make this a more relaxing
and enjoyable experience for all of you,
and less caffeinated.
So maybe you're preparing for, you know,
an important architecture
review this afternoon
and, you know, you actually have a lot
of research tasks for this.
You've gotta check out, you know, what are
the latest LLM benchmarks,
maybe you have to check out
your competitor API changes,
emerging security
advisories for your stack.
And then you've gotta get
that all into Confluence.
So I know you're thinking to yourself,
"She said this was
gonna be more relaxing."
And here's why it is,
we can now today put this
all together in a workflow.
So instead of having to do all
these different tasks, right,
maybe going over to Quick Research
and, you know, doing all of that manually
and then summarizing it, still
copying and pasting into,
you know, various documents,
we can now do this in
step-by-step workflows
within Quick Research.
So I'm really excited to share that
and dive deeper into that with you today.
So you heard from Jon earlier,
you've already seen this slide,
but I'm gonna take a couple minutes
to dive a little bit deeper into it now
because at this point we're
gonna be talking about
how several Quick Suite
capabilities work together
to make this happen.
So I'm gonna start at the bottom.
I'd like to think of this
as like our knowledge layer.
And so we have company
data, we have connectors
to both unstructured data sets.
Think of like SharePoint,
Google Drive, right?
Confluence, uploaded files, right?
We also have connectors
for structured data,
think Snowflake, Redshift,
those types of things.
All of those, when you
curate them into a space,
can be used within Quick
Research as knowledge sources.
We also have a concept called actions.
Those are for real time,
you know, both read and write actions
with third party applications.
And so we have native
connectors to a lot of sources
as well as, you know, API and MCP
where you can use those to connect.
And so examples there might be, you know,
you might use Quick
Suite to give you a list
of Jira tickets assigned to you
or maybe, you know, send an email
or, you know, post
something to Slack or Teams.
And so while actions are not yet supported
within Quick Research,
they are supported within our chat agents
and our automations.
And that's gonna be important in a moment.
So this middle layer,
we don't have time to
talk about that today,
but that's our governance
and securely layer
and I just wanna make sure, right?
You're all thinking about that.
Of course, if you're using research
in this company environment
and you're putting your
company data in it,
you know, you definitely need
to be thinking about having
a product that, you know,
takes this into account
and for which it's really important.
And then at the top, again,
Jon did introduce these to you,
but just to reiterate,
right, we have spaces
where you're gonna curate these
various knowledge sources.
Those can be used within
chat agents, within Research.
With Quick Sight, you're
able to have dashboards
and scenario analysis, and
then we get to our automations.
So flows, as Jon mentioned,
is more for like team
and personal productivity, right?
You're gonna see in a moment
we're gonna really dive
deeper into flows.
I also wanna tell you about automate,
automate is for generally
more complex workflows.
You can mix both like deterministic
and non-deterministic types
of steps into, you know,
pretty complex things.
And we will bring this up in a moment
as part of one of our examples,
but we're gonna really
be focusing on flows.
And the reason for that is
because what we released
last Friday was actually
the ability to call
research within a flow.
So flows are really easy
to get started with.
Anybody here,
any business user should be
able to get started with flows
because you use natural language
to describe the workflow that you want.
And it's gonna actually, once you do that,
it's gonna automatically build out some
editable steps for you.
So I'm gonna dive a little bit deeper into
what that means, right?
If you're deciding to use a research step.
So first, flows are gonna let you create
reusable research workflows.
Nicki was just talking about
how important prompts are, right?
For research. And think about that.
Like if you're just doing it manually,
you have the opportunity
like Jon showed you
to go back and forth and to
really refine the outline
and refine what you want
out of the research.
But once you're getting into
automation, you wanna make sure
that saved prompt is really solid.
And so what I think is really
great about the way we do it
in flows is you can create
this reusable prompt,
but you can also have input parameters.
So variables.
So when somebody's running
this, like in my case,
I'll show you in a
moment, all I have to do
is enter the customer name
and all of a sudden that
prompt is personalized,
but it's a vetted prompt, right?
That somebody put in here to
then share with their team.
There's also gonna be
situations where, you know,
you don't want your
team copying and pasting
and maybe making edits, right?
You maybe have taken the
time to really, you know,
do that prompt engineering
and you know you wanna
have consistent output.
So the thing with flows too is, you know,
if they're running the
flow you shared with them,
they can't make that edit
on the prompt, right?
They're just gonna be able to change the
input parameters and that's it.
The other thing, right,
that works with flows is
the ability to then have
different types of steps
before or after it.
So in my situation here,
I do have an input step,
but then after that I'm
getting meeting notes,
I'm gonna generate speaking points,
I'm gonna send a Slack message,
and I'm gonna dive into this in a moment
and we'll get a little
bit more under the hood.
So before I do that, what I'm
gonna do is do a little bit
before and after, show and tell, right?
So for me, as I mentioned,
I work a lot with customers.
So a big part of my
daily life is preparing
for meetings with customers.
And here's how it used to
work for me before, right?
I would have to look at my calendar,
figure out what my customer meetings are,
take a look at that agenda, right?
So I know what I need to prepare for.
And then, I like to do
web research, right?
I like to go to their website,
I like to do some, you know,
some just checking the search
engine, checking the news.
What are some initiatives
that are important
to our customers so that
I can understand, right,
how AWS can help them.
On the other side, I'm also
doing internal research.
So I actually only joined
AWS a little over a year ago.
And I will tell you that
when I first started,
this took me a lot of time, right?
Understanding all the
different AWS services,
understanding what case
studies are available, right?
As you can imagine, we have
so much different documentation available,
not only externally,
but internally as well,
to support all of you guys, right?
And then by the time I'm
done, I'm making a plan,
I'm synthesizing that
to share it, you know,
with our account team or for myself.
And that, I mean honestly can
take anywhere from 15 minutes
to an hour, used to.
Now here's how I'm getting a
lot of that done in 10 seconds,
which is crazy, right?
So whenever I agree to
a new customer meeting,
I start my flow, I literally
type the customer name
and hit enter.
From there, it's gonna
kick off a research step.
That research step is gonna
check both public sources
and it's also connected
to my Quick Suite space.
So that's a curated space that we have
that includes both external documentation
as well as some of those
internal resources, right?
With the case studies and, you know,
industry use cases, things like that.
Separately, I'm actually
using a chat agent step
and I could have done
this as separate actions,
but my chat agent step
is a bit more efficient
in that I have it set up to
check my email, my Slack,
my OneDrive notes,
my calendar, right?
So that's where it's
kind of doing all of my
connected internal company
sources to, you know,
make sure that this flow
understands, you know,
what is my history with this customer.
After that, we're gonna
generate some speaking points.
So I have a step that we call a
Quick Suite data step, right?
It's gonna take the results
from these previous steps
and it's gonna combine that along with
an additional prompt
to create those speaking
points in a format that I like.
And then the last one,
I'm actually sending
myself a Slack message.
'Cause I like to read things in Slack,
and you know, it's just helpful
to refer back to quickly.
So a couple things here that
I really wanna point out.
When, you know, a lot of
times when we're talking
to people about automations,
sometimes people get scared
because they're like,
"Oh, I still need a human in the loop."
And I wanna tell you that
that is super important
and built into our flows.
So there's a couple different
ways that that is the case.
One is, when I'm sending
the Slack message,
I mean for myself, this
doesn't matter as much,
but if I was to send
something like posting
to a team channel or something,
I'd wanna approve that
before it sends, right?
Definitely before I'm sending an email
or something like that.
You can actually add in additional inputs
so that at any point
in time you can kind of
stop the flow before you
let it continue running
if you want to verify it.
I can go back to any of the previous steps
so I can, you know,
and sometimes that's important.
I'm reviewing the meeting speaking notes
and I wanna dive into something deeper.
I can go back to that research report,
I can take a look at the
sources, you know, I can go back
and see what it's pulling from my notes,
and I can even chat with the flow to say,
"Hey, you know, can you update this?"
Maybe I wasn't fully satisfied
with one particular step.
So very important to have that, you know,
the idea behind this is definitely not
to just do everything for you
and, you know, move forward.
It's to make you a better employee
and to be able to just spend your time
on the more strategic work
as it relates to the research
and, you know, taking action from it.
So now the flow I just showed
you was on demand, right?
Meaning I run it with my specific inputs
whenever I have a meeting to prepare for.
But flows can also be scheduled
to run automatically on a recurring basis.
And I think that's, you
know, that's perfect.
There's certain things that
you know you need to do
on a consistent and predictable basis.
So example, maybe, right,
every Monday, you know that you need
to stay current on your
cloud infrastructure updates.
And ideally this is something
that you're just gonna schedule.
You don't wanna have to
remember to kick it off, right?
So what you can do is actually
schedule it with research.
You can do it daily, weekly, right?
Whatever makes the most sense.
And so what I think is
really awesome about this,
this is another thing that
we just launched last week.
It's turning research
from not only reactive,
meaning like, okay, I know I need to go
research this now in
response to something,
but being proactive, meaning
like the research is ready
before I'm even ready to think about it.
And that's really helpful.
So I wanna show you how
one of our customers
is planning to use this at scale.
AstraZeneca is a leading global
biopharmaceutical company.
They came to us with a challenge
that I think really
demonstrates well the power
of automated research.
So let's start with their goals.
One of the key AstraZeneca therapy areas,
working with their IT colleagues,
wanted to enhance their
intelligent alerts capabilities.
And they had three main drivers.
One, market leadership acceleration.
So they wanted proactive alerts
on the latest scientific outcomes
so they could rapidly
capture opportunities
and make informed business decisions.
Second, they're thinking a lot about
strategic executive empowerment
by automating intelligence
gathering into alerts.
This is gonna free up their leaders
to focus on high value
strategic decision making
and not spend as much
time sifting through data.
And third, real-time
competitive advantage, right?
They wanna use agents to remove the need
for information review
via multiple channels.
And so they came to us saying,
"Hey, we need a solution
with three very specific
requirements," right?
They wanna aggregate real-time insights
across multiple sources,
named sources, from the past 24 hours.
These might include scientific
journals, regulatory filings,
and competitor updates.
Next, they wanna summarize
this breaking news,
but specifically tailored
to their projects
and therapeutic areas, right?
That analysis is really important.
A lot of times you think
about research as, you know,
just gathering information,
but Quick Research does an amazing job
with analyzing that as well.
Last, they wanna send leadership summaries
that are accurate, timely, relevant,
and not duplicative,
they don't wanna waste
their leader's time,
with proper scientific
citations for onward review.
So let's talk about the approach.
Actually for me it was
really cool experience
when this project kicked off.
'Cause they came to us and said,
"Hey, we just spent two hours
with Quick Research and flows.
We've been trying other tools,
but we can see immediately
how this is going
to help us scale, but in a
tailored approach, right,
to help our R&D colleagues."
And so this is how we
started working with them.
We started thinking first
about the data sources.
So when this project kicked
off, we did not yet have
the capability that Jon
mentioned about being able
to specify specific websites.
And so as I mentioned earlier,
their requirement was really, you know,
gathering data from named sources.
And so we approached this
in two different ways.
One is we have a web crawler
data connector, right?
So as you recall in my
Quick Suite diagram, right,
we have these managed connectors,
front structured data.
One of those is a web crawler.
So we are using that
for some of the sources.
And then we're actually
also using quick automate.
Quick automate has UI agent
capabilities built into it.
And those UI agents, you can, you know,
give it some instructions
to go to websites to
look for information.
And that is actually how we
are gathering information
from some of the other sources.
From there, right, they started to say,
"Okay, well how can we optimize
the research and analysis piece?"
And there's three things I wanna share
with you on that piece.
So one is they experimented
with single versus multiple reports.
So what they found is that
for their particular use case,
they actually decided that
they were getting better results
when they split some of their
prompts into various reports.
They also talked about
website content filtering.
So because they had made this decision
to kind of curate the
data sources elsewhere,
not using the features
from Quick Research,
they actually decided to turn web off.
So they are truly using
the research, right,
purely on company data
that's already been curated,
and not going out to the web in real time
when they run research.
The last thing is they
had this date requirement,
they really wanna focus
on the last 24 hours.
And so that took some prompt
engineering within research
to be able to make sure
that it's really focusing on
that last 24 hours.
And so finally, you know,
now they're pulling it all together
with the Quick Flows, right?
That's consolidating
some of these reports,
deduplicating against previous reports,
validating, and then getting to the point
where it sends a leadership
email in a very beautiful
HTML format in Outlook.
So what's next for this project?
So this MVP is about to
go to production soon
and based on the work to date,
AstraZeneca sees value in
continuing to invest in scale.
So I'm very happy about that.
Their optimization plans
include actually moving to APIs
for some of the sources that support them
because, you know, that's gonna
help reduce the web crawler
and UI agent processing time.
And I think this is good insight, right?
Not every single step
has to be agentic, right?
There are definitely times
where you still wanna use APIs
and go straight to the source.
They're also gonna be
measuring retrieval precision
for some of those web crawlers,
and seeing if they can make
some improvements there.
They're also continuing
to measure success, right?
That's important to really
get the business confidence
in this.
So they're benchmarking
performance and accuracy.
And then they're planning to scale.
They wanna monitor more
therapeutic areas and sources.
They wanna get insights
from the end users in R&D
who are receiving these alerts, right?
They wanna make sure that they can tailor
and enhance the experience,
and then they do plan
to actually move from a semi-automation
to full automation once they've achieved
the business confidence in this.
All right, so we heard from
Jon all the ways Quick Research
can empower your teams.
You know, you heard from Nicki
how Principal Financial Group
is transforming their research
and analysis across multiple use cases.
You heard from me, you know,
how AstraZeneca is automating
their alerts process
all using Quick Research.
So at this point, I really want you
to now start exploring what's possible.
So if you scan these QR
codes, there's two here.
One is for our Quick Suite community
and the other is for
our AWS Skill Builder.
So if you're not familiar with
the Quick Sight community,
I really encourage this resource.
Not only do we have like
tens of thousands of members
that participate in forums
and help each other out
with using Quick Suite,
including of course our own moderators.
We post events, we have weekly
and monthly events that,
you know, sometimes are
virtual, sometimes live.
We have tons of learning resources,
we have interactive demos.
So please check out that community.
- Thank you very much.
- Thank you everyone.